good i just uh
wanted to say that we've had a long
discussion in in cabinet for
a couple of hours now a very good
discussion in which we agreed that the
the situation is extremely difficult and
the the arguments either way are very
very finely balanced because we've got
cases of omicron surging across the
country now we've got hospitalizations
uh rising quite steeply in uh in london
and the obvious conclusion is that of
course it was right to go fast for plan
b in the way that we we did and also
right to double the speed of the booster
uh rollout to make sure that everybody
got their boosters as fast as as
possible
and uh
in view of the the balance of risks and
uh and uncertainties particularly around
uh the infection hospitalization rate of
uh of omicron how many uh people does
omicron uh put into hospital of the of
the infected uh and some other
uncertainties to do with uh severity and
booster effectiveness and uh and so on
uh we agreed that we should keep the the
data from now on under constant a review
keep uh following it uh
hour by hour and
unfortunately i must say to people we we
will have to
reserve the the
possibility of taking further action to
to protect the public
uh and to protect public health to
protect uh our nhs
and we won't hesitate to take that
action
but in the meantime what i would say to
everybody is
um please exercise caution as you as you
as you go about your lives uh please
think of the of the guidance and i think
protecting yourself and and your loved
ones
and um
please get a booster please get a
vaccination
it could not be more urgent there are
still millions of people in this country
who haven't got
a vaccination let alone uh a booster
and
it makes such a difference the evidence
is overwhelming it's such a positive
thing to do and i i say to to you know
that all those people who are
unvaccinated whether out of uh apathy or
uh for whatever uh whatever reason uh
please please please think of this as a
as a great thing to do
for yourself and for your family if your
community get boosted now can i ask you
what that caution actually looks like
what should people not be doing and
you're keeping this under review can you
guarantee there won't be restrictions
before christmas and after christmas
lots of talk about banning indoor mixing
new limits on pubs and restaurants can
you level with us and at least tell us
what you're looking at
yes i can certainly say that we're we're
looking at all kinds of things uh
anushka to uh to keep uh omicron under
control and we we will rule uh nothing
out but at the moment what i think that
we we want people to focus on
uh is
um
exercising caution so ventilation uh
masks in the in the appropriate places
uh all the the usual stuff about washing
hands but remember how contagious
omicron
really is and i think what you're seeing
already is the the british public
understanding that and you can see in
people's patterns of behavior since we
went to to plan b that they are changing
the way they go about their lives they
are changing some of the assumptions
they make about the things that they
that they want to do and i'm afraid to
say and i know that that has had uh
consequences for some parts of our
economy and some parts of the
hospitality section uh you know i i of
course i in many ways i regret that but
if it can help to get down the r uh get
down the the way the the disease is
multiplying that can be very helpful uh
to us and and to the country but what
really matters
is for everybody to to get vaccinated
and get boosted above all because the
booster really does give you a very high
level of protection i mean you talk
about consequences devastating
consequences for many pubs for many
restaurants for theaters that are on
their knees can you give financial
support to those sectors now
of course i i understand how tough it it
must be and
nobody wanted things to to to go this
way omicron has simply uh exploded so
fast that uh you know we've we've seen
people naturally deciding uh to to to
make sure that they they protect
themselves and they avoid spreading the
disease and as i said uh the benefits of
that course of action uh we may see
in uh the next few days and weeks in the
way we're able to contain that ease it
but it is important that we act
cautiously and of course it's also
important that we look after the
hospitality sector theaters and other
parts of our incredible entertainment
industry which which will uh will suffer
in our suffering so there are packages
of uh funding already in places the
there's a business rate relief the the
vat
relief
but also uh funds available uh from uh
from local councils which have surpluses
in their funds to to give support and we
will again like all these things we will
keep the economic
side of this under constant review as
well i mean prime minister there is a
trust issue here you're asking people to
be cautious they see the picture of you
sitting in the downing street garden
drinking wine eating cheese at a time
when
you know those were not within the rules
they don't buy that it's a work meeting
there are people on twitter who say they
had funerals of loved ones in the same
week and they couldn't have that many
people at their funerals do you
understand why people are angry and why
they might be less likely to do what you
say
those
were people
at work talking about work
so you were having a work meeting there
without laptops without any notes or
paper do you normally have wine and
cheese at work those were people at work
those were meetings of people at work
talking about this is where i live and
to where i work those were meetings of
people at work talking about work and i
really think it's vital that we focus if
we can on
the the messages we're trying to get
across today we face a serious spike in
uh in omicron and you're seeing the the
cases go up in in london particularly
the cases of hospitalizations
and
the answer is to be cautious but also to
get vaccinated saturday was an amazing
day for vaccinations
i think a million across the uk
sunday was uh also almost a million uh
we're seeing record numbers come forward
almost i think over half the adult
population has now been vaccinated but
now is the time for those missing
millions uh to help themselves but also
to help the whole country through a
difficult time just a quick final one
prime minister the sage minutes are very
clear that early intervention matters
and that the earlier you intervene the
shorter the restrictions can stay in
place that means now why aren't you
taking their advice we went as you
remember anushka as soon as we saw what
was happening with omicron and and you
will remember it was very controversial
and there were many colleagues in
parliament who said no this goes too far
but we went ahead uh with plan b uh
virtually straight away and i think that
was the right thing to do and uh we also
doubled the speed of the vaccine rollout
we we
went into into overdrive with the
vaccine rather with the with the the
booster in particular
there are still some things that we need
to be uh clearer about
before we decide to go further anushka
but i've got to say to the british
public and i say to everybody we will
not exclude uh going further if we have
to to do things to protect the public
the public are already
taking steps to protect each other and
protect themselves and it's uh you know
it's wonderful to see and it's wonderful
to see how many people are coming
forward to be vaccinated i say thank you
to them thank you to the incredible army
of
vaccinators and all the volunteers it's
it's it's wonderful the campaign is as
you know we vaccinated uh more people as
a percentage of our population virtually
uh any anywhere else and that that is
that is great uh but
we need to
do more and to get the levels of
protection we're going to need against
omicron there are millions of people who
still need to get boosted millions of of
adults
there is a slot for you
uh for every adult uh before the end of
the year
we we're gonna give you a slot get that
jab and just to be clear you'll relax
with people drinking during work that's
part of the rules you're quite relaxed
with that happening when people are in
offices
look i've said what i've said about that
thank you